James Franco snubbed by the Oscars in
the wake of allegations of inappropriate
behavior
[Music]
despite being an award season
frontrunner Franco failed to nab a Best
Actor Oscar nom for his role in the
disaster artist on Tuesday the 39 year
olds already took home the Golden Globe
and the Critics Choice Award for his
performance the snub comes after
multiple women accused Franco of abuse
of power and inappropriate behavior in
an article published in the Los Angeles
Times on January 11 two of those women
spoke out to Good Morning America again
on Tuesday he created exploitative
environments for non celebrity women on
his sets a source close to Franco tells
et that the accusations against the
actor are quote false Franco addressed
the allegations himself during a recent
stop by The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert I completely support people
coming out and being able to have a
voice because they didn't have a voice
for so long so I don't want to I don't
want to you know shut them down in any
way it's it's I think a good thing and I
supported
[Music]
you